on pourrait la croire en pleines
révisions du bac et on se tromperait
carré louise recense surtout les
réponses de milliers de lycéens réponses
à un questionnaire envoyé par le conseil
national de la vie lycéenne et le
constat est saisissant
on a aussi une question sur cette année
scolaire vous semble-t-elle meilleure
que celle de l'an passé
la situation fait qu'il ya eu énormément
de personnes distincts qui vont voir les
artilleurs scolaires pour la fouille a
vraiment fait des choses qu'on une
poussette d'angoua ce qu'on voyait pas
avant
héloïse est un des 60 membres du conseil
national de la vie lycéenne chargé de
dialoguer avec le ministère et de faire
des propositions comme l'annulation de
l'épreuve de philo et celle nouvelle du
grant aurait dû terminal de cette année
sur le grand oral a passé voilà il ne se
sent pas forcément prêts par rapport à
tout ça c'est vrai que j'ai aussi une
égalité des chances en fonction des
enseignements
il y en a qui ont reçu des enseignements
peut-être plus poussée dans certains
lycées peut-être voilà tout ce qu'ils
ont eu à l'enseignement hybride avec
instantiel plus prononcé que dans
d'autres lycées
donc c'est vrai que ça mais pas
forcément tout le monde sur le même pied
d'égalité
le questionnaire a aussi largement
circulé via l'application tik tok de
quoi affiner les revendication
l'annulation des épreuves du bac ne veut
pas dire qu'il n'aura pas donc c'est en
fait c'est comme ça serait comme une
dernière avec un contrôle continu
ce puits sont contre
cette pièce sur le contrôle continu
voilà donc une autre qui que les élèves
ont eu tout au long de l'année
quand les évaluer lors du bac bonjour ce
coup vous a pas dit c'est qu'héloïse est
en seconde et qu'elle passe quinze
heures par semaine sur ces questions
nationales demain elle échangera en
visio directement avec le ministre
bloquèrent qui ne reviendra pas sur
l'organisation des épreuves première et
terminale doivent donc se préparer à
passer le bac de français et de
philosophie
le jeudi 17 juin